to what extent is there an existential
risk or existential threat from AI it's
nonzero and the more that uh but the
more that we talk about it the the less
likely it becomes and the reason why is
that it like the idea that we're going
to you know hand over our launch missile
codes to an AI and then go to the beach
only to find out that there's a mushroom
cloud on the horizon is pretty remote on
the other hand in very um very miniature
ways we need to be vigilant so we
wouldn't want to handle off um if we
have a trading system at a bank um we
wouldn't want to hand it off all to an
AI without a human somehow in the loop
particularly maybe as a as a control
switch so if things start running a muck
we can have someone look at it and
realize things are indeed a muck and
they can slow it down and control
[Music]
it